cristóbal las declaraciones de joe biden
resumieron bastante las acciones
estadounidenses desde el inicio de la
guerra lo escuchamos
si resumen lo que ha venido haciendo
eeuu con estas rondas de sanciones y
esta sanción esta nueva ronda de
sanciones a privados y a la duma en
general a la duma que es la que actúa
como la asamblea el parlamento ruso los
328 miembros de la duma quedan
sancionados entonces no podrán hacer
transacciones en eeuu sus activos en
este país quedan congelados así también
como los las 28 48 perdón a empresas de
defensas rusas que también pues no
podrán hacer negocios con eeuu es entre
están sancionados también german gref
que es el presidente del banco sberbank
que es el banco más grande en rusia y
pues sus activos entonces en este país
también quedan congelados es de resaltar
esta ayuda humanitaria es una ayuda
humanitaria de mil millones de dólares
que irán específicamente a proveer
comida alimentos y medicamentos a los
refugiados ya son más de 3 millones de
refugiados ya salí del ucrania sobre
todo
polonia y pues en ese sentido el
presidente yo vayan también resaltó que
para abrir la puerta 100 mil ucranianos
100 mil ucranianos que ya tienen familia
en este país estos son los que tendrán
prioridad para entrar pronto a eeuu
desde ucrania una reunificación familiar
que decía el presidente joe biden además
cristóbal esta es una noticia en la que
veníamos hablando de france24 como
previsión desde la semana pasada tanto
el anuncio de más sanciones como las
visitas a estas cumbres de la otan y el
g7 y la unión europea y además mañana el
presidente de los eeuu visita en polonia
a los refugiados que han logrado huir
desde ucrania precisamente en ese
contexto le quiero preguntar cómo avanza
la agenda de joe biden hasta el momento
y que se espera que salga al final de
toda esta gira con reuniones de alto
nivel
pues hay muchas críticas frente a el
impacto real que pueda tener este nuevo
ciclo de sanciones de que sonia a más de
600 individuos rusos individuos que han
estado muy conectados que creen que se
han beneficiado de los negocios con el
gobierno ruso en todo el mundo y lo que
le critican entonces a estas sanciones
algunos analistas es que si se pueden
sancionar los negocios que tienen estos
individuos rusos en europa y en eeuu
pero al final estas personas están
empresas están usando empresas fantasmas
o testaferros para poder evadir estas
sanciones y entonces pues el mensaje que
puede salir de acá es que a pesar de
estas curvas que pueden hacer estos
oligarcas rusos para abrir las sanciones
pues hay unidad hay unidad tanto en la
otan como en occidente eeuu la unión
europea el g7 está unido y está unido
sobre todo en este mensaje que dijo joe
biden hace unos minutos de querer sacar
precisamente a rusia del g20 unido
también en el mensaje que le envían a
china que le dicen que por favor respete
el orden internacional que no se le
ocurra enviar armas a rusia y también
unido en el mensaje de que las
consecuencias serán severas en caso de
que rusia use armas químicas o nucleares
en territorio ucraniano